This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanatham. There's a pattern in Hollywood stories about romance and passion. The lovers may face all kinds of obstacles, but the movies end on a high note. The couple kiss as the ball drops on New Year's Eve. They embrace on a beach at sunset. They celebrate at a wedding. The 1967 movie The Graduate does something a bit different. Benjamin Braddock, played by Dustin Hoffman, gate crashes the wedding of his soulmate, Elaine Robinson, played by
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。好莱坞关于浪漫与激情的电影故事中存在一种模式。恋人们可能会面临各种障碍，但电影总会以圆满结局收场。新年前夜，随着跨年倒计时的钟声，情侣们深情拥吻；他们在日落的海滩上拥抱；他们在婚礼上庆祝。1967年的电影《毕业生》则有些不同。达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演的本杰明·布拉多克闯入了灵魂伴侣伊莱恩·罗宾逊的婚礼，而伊莱恩由
Catherine Ross. He interrupts the ceremony and shouts, Elaine, from the balcony of the church. After a moment of hesitation, Elaine shouts back BAM! and runs to him, rejecting her bridegroom and her parents' expectations. The two escape the church amidst chaos, with Elaine's family and the wedding guests trying to stop them. The young couple fight off the crowd using a large wooden cross, which Benjamin uses to block the church doors as they make their getaway. Elaine and Benjamin then board a city bus sitting at the back together. As the bus drives away, they initially laugh, exhilarated by their daring escape.
凯瑟琳·罗斯饰演。他在教堂的阳台上打断了仪式，大喊着“伊莱恩”。经过片刻的犹豫，伊莱恩大喊一声“本！”，随即奔向他，拒绝了新郎和父母的期望。两人在混乱中逃离教堂，伊莱恩的家人和婚礼宾客试图阻拦他们。这对年轻情侣用一个巨大的木十字架击退人群，本杰明用它挡住教堂大门，随后他们成功逃脱。伊莱恩和本杰明登上一辆城市公交车，坐在后排。当车开走时，他们起初大笑，为大胆的逃离感到兴奋。
However, and this is where the movie veers from the Hollywood formula, their expressions slowly shift to a more subdued and ambiguous tone. Their expressions slowly shift to a more subdued and ambiguous tone. The camera lingers on their faces as Simon and Garfunkel's The Sound of Silence plays in the background. Elaine and Benjamin seem to be asking, what now? Starting a love affair is one thing. Figuring out how to sustain their love is harder and will demand more skill and maturity. love is harder and will demand more skill and maturity. What is true in our personal relationships is also true in our professional lives.
然而——电影正是从这里偏离了好莱坞的套路——他们的表情慢慢变得压抑而暧昧。他们的表情慢慢变得压抑而暧昧。当西蒙和加芬克尔的《寂静之声》在背景中响起时，镜头在他们的脸上停留。伊莱恩和本杰明似乎在问：接下来怎么办？开始一段恋情是一回事，弄清楚如何维持这份爱则更难，需要更多的技巧和成熟。爱是更难的，需要更多的技巧和成熟。我们在个人关系中体会到的真理，在职业生涯中同样适用。
There comes a time when the things we once engaged in with pleasure and passion grow boring or unfulfilling. Today on the show and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Brain+, we look at the signs of what makes passion fade. We'll focus on our work lives, but some of the lessons apply to our personal relationships too. What we get wrong about deep engagement, and how to keep our passions alive, this week on Hidden Brain. It's the oldest aphorism at college commencement ceremonies.
总有一天，我们曾经乐在其中、充满激情的事物会变得枯燥或无法满足我们。今天在节目中，以及在《隐藏的大脑+》的配套故事里，我们将探讨激情消退的迹象。我们将重点关注工作生活，但其中一些经验也适用于个人关系。关于深度投入的误区，以及如何保持激情，尽在本周的《隐藏的大脑》。这是大学毕业典礼上最古老的格言。
Follow your passion. Find something you love, and your future will take care of itself. At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist Jan Jahimovic studies how our passions change over time and how we can manage them long term. Jan Jahimovic, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar.
追随你的激情。找到你热爱的事物，你的未来自然会水到渠成。在哈佛商学院，行为科学家简·贾希莫维奇研究了我们的激情如何随时间变化，以及我们如何长期管理它们。简·贾希莫维奇，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡尔。
Jan, as a young man, you wanted to change the world. And I understand this drive was partly connected with your own family's story of migration and loss? Yeah, let me back up a little bit. So both of my parents grew up in Warsaw, Poland, in the aftermath of World War II, and they were Jewish. In 1968, there was economic stagnation and crises that led to a student protest. In response, the Polish government led an anti-Semitic campaign. Jews face a lot of hostility.
简，年轻时你曾想改变世界。我了解到这种动力部分与你家族的移民和失落史有关？是的，让我稍微回顾一下。我的父母都在二战后的波兰华沙长大，他们是犹太人。1968年，经济停滞和危机引发了学生抗议。作为回应，波兰政府发动了一场反犹太运动。犹太人面临着巨大的敌意。
My father's mother, so my grandmother on my father's side, she worked at the University of Warsaw, and one day she walked into her office and she tried to open the door to her office with her key and the key didn't work anymore. She asked the janitor what was going on and the janitor said that her lock had been changed because she was no longer allowed to be there. And so in response to the discrimination and hostility, the vast majority of Jews ended up leaving Poland, including both of my parents and my extended family. They all left. Both of my parents ultimately settled in Germany. That's where my father ended up getting a job and that's where
我父亲的母亲，也就是我的祖母，她在华沙大学工作。有一天，她走进办公室，试图用钥匙开门，但钥匙打不开了。她问门卫发生了什么事，门卫说她的锁被换了，因为她不再被允许待在那里。为了应对这种歧视和敌意，绝大多数犹太人最终离开了波兰，包括我的父母和我的大家庭。他们都离开了。我的父母最终定居在德国。我父亲在那里找到了工作，也就是在那里
they built a new life for us and that's where I was born and raised. I was born and raised. Jan says life was hard for immigrants in Germany. The family struggled and felt isolated. Social mobility was difficult. Jan found himself wishing the world was a fairer and kinder place. After he graduated high school, he stumbled on a book that seemed to speak to him directly.
他们为我们建立了新的生活，我也就是在那里出生长大的。我出生并长大。简说，移民在德国的生活很艰难。家庭生活拮据，感到孤立无援。社会流动性很困难。简发现自己希望世界能变得更公平、更友善。高中毕业后，他偶然发现了一本书，似乎直接触动了他的心弦。
This book was Mountains Beyond Mountains. It was written by Tracy Kidder, who wrote a biography of Dr. Paul Farmer. Paul Farmer famously was a public health advocate who started Partners in Health, started off in Haiti and then scaled the organization all around the world. And the book at the time when I was 18, it transformed me. In the book, you see Tracy Kidder writing about Paul taking on these challenges that you think are impossible. There's this story in the book of a boy who has a tumor on his face.
这本书是《高山之外的高山》。它由特雷西·基德撰写，讲述了保罗·法默医生的传记。保罗·法默是一位著名的公共卫生倡导者，他创办了“健康伙伴”组织，从海地起步，随后将该组织扩展到全球。那年我18岁，这本书改变了我。在书中，你看到特雷西·基德描写保罗如何挑战那些你认为不可能完成的任务。书里有一个故事，讲的是一个脸上长了肿瘤的男孩。
And the boy lives in Haiti and there's no one in Haiti that can perform that surgery. And the only way to perform that surgery would be to fly that boy to Boston and get him surgery there. Paul, at the time, was relatively early in his career, but he had this belief that he could make it happen. He could organize transport somehow for this boy to Boston.
这个男孩住在海地，海地没有人能做这种手术。进行手术的唯一方法是把男孩送到波士顿接受治疗。保罗当时职业生涯还处于早期，但他坚信自己能做到。他坚信能以某种方式组织交通，把男孩送到波士顿。
He would convince a team of surgeons somehow to take on this surgery, make sure that the boy's recovery works, and then fly him back. And it worked out. Like, that's the crazy thing is he had this belief. And I walked away from that thinking like, wow, maybe I can do this too.
他会设法说服一个外科医生团队来承担这项手术，确保男孩康复，然后再送他回去。结果成功了。这太疯狂了，他竟然有这种信念。我读完后心想，哇，也许我也能做到。
Like, maybe this is what I want to do with my life. I want to pursue something that I am passionate about and take that to the next step. Another lesson in the book was about the power of going all in. No hesitations, no questions, full speed ahead. How did that strike you, Jan? When I was 18, I loved it. This is what I wanted to hear, that it's okay to just go all in and that that will be rewarded. To feel like you have that much conviction, that much belief
也许这就是我想用一生去做的事。我想追求我所热爱的事物，并将其推向下一步。书中的另一个教训是关于“全力以赴”的力量。没有犹豫，没有疑问，全速前进。简，这给你留下了什么印象？18岁时，我喜欢极了。这就是我想听到的，全力以赴是没问题的，而且会得到回报。那种拥有如此坚定的信念，如此强烈的信仰，
in something, that you're willing to place everything on it. I mean, who doesn't want to feel that way? That's an amazing feeling to have. And I aspire to have that feeling as well. The book tells a story about a patient living in a remote area in Haiti who was too ill to make the trip to Paul Farmer's clinic. So Paul Farmer goes to the patient. He has to hike four and a half hours each way to the patient. And the book asks why Paul Farmer left a busy clinic to treat one patient, and the doctor says, the idea that some lives matter less is the root of all that's wrong with the world.
以至于愿意孤注一掷的感觉。谁不想有这种感觉呢？这是一种美妙的感觉。我也渴望拥有这种感觉。书中讲述了一位住在海地偏远地区的病人，他病得太重，无法前往保罗·法默的诊所。于是保罗·法默亲自去找病人。他必须往返徒步四个半小时才能到达病人那里。书中问为什么保罗·法默要离开繁忙的诊所去治疗一个病人，医生回答说：“认为某些生命比其他生命更不重要的想法，是世界上所有罪恶的根源。”
That's a powerfully idealistic vision that no lives are dispensable, yeah. It showed me that you can have a deep belief and a deep value about what you think is right, and that at the end of the day, you have to decide what you think is the right thing to do. And for Paul Farmer, the right thing to do was hiking four to five hours to see one patient because that patient wouldn't otherwise be able to receive medical care. So Paul Farmer was often asked if he felt depressed by all the injustice he saw in the world,
那是一个强有力的理想主义愿景，即没有生命是多余的，是的。它向我展示了你可以拥有深刻的信念和价值观，关于你认为什么是对的，归根结底，你必须决定你认为什么是正确的事。对保罗·法默来说，正确的事就是徒步四五个小时去见一个病人，因为如果不这样做，那个病人就无法获得医疗护理。所以保罗·法默经常被问到，他是否会因为看到世界上所有的不公正而感到沮丧，
and he would respond by saying, there's no better insurance against depression than to actively fight injustice. How did that sentiment strike you, Jan? I was so excited about that because I was feeling the weight of the world's problems on my shoulders. Like I was seeing the challenges ahead of me,
他会回答说：“对抗不公正本身，就是预防抑郁症最好的良药。”简，这种情绪给你留下了什么印象？我当时非常兴奋，因为我感到肩上扛着世界问题的重担。我看到了摆在面前的挑战，
the challenges that I was facing in Germany, the challenges that I was learning about as a young man. And it's hard not to get discouraged. I mean, you look at the news and the only thing you see is this bad thing is happening and this bad actor has done something. It's really hard to maintain a sense of optimism that, you know, change is possible and in fact that like people can make a difference. And then to hear Paul Farmer say, if you feel that way, the solution is to do something about it. And once you do something about it, you no longer feel that way. I felt really excited.
我在德国面临的挑战，以及我作为一个年轻人所了解到的挑战。很难不感到气馁。你看新闻，看到的只有坏事发生，坏人做了坏事。要保持一种乐观的态度真的很难，即相信改变是可能的，事实上，人们是可以有所作为的。然后听到保罗·法默说，如果你有这种感觉，解决办法就是采取行动。一旦你采取了行动，你就不会再有那种感觉了。我感到非常兴奋。
It really enthralled me and it pulled me in. I didn't know how to do it. I didn't know what exactly I would do, but I knew at the time this is what I wanted to do. Jan swallowed what he called the passion pill. After college, he went to Columbia University in New York to pursue graduate studies. He wanted to do research that would change public policy and change the world. After two or three years of very hard work, he came up with a paper about the power of social ties in Bangladesh. It showed that meaningful social connections could be an engine of upward mobility. The kind of upward mobility his own immigrant family had yearned for in Germany.
它真的吸引了我，让我深陷其中。我不知道该怎么做。我不知道具体要做什么，但我当时就知道这就是我想做的事。简吞下了他所谓的“激情药丸”。大学毕业后，他去了纽约的哥伦比亚大学攻读研究生。他想做能改变公共政策、改变世界的研究。经过两三年非常艰苦的工作，他写出了一篇关于孟加拉国社会关系力量的论文。它表明，有意义的社会联系可以成为向上流动的引擎。这正是他自己的移民家庭在德国所渴望的那种向上流动。
This paper is so very personally meaningful to me. I was so excited about getting it published. It had been a long slog to get to this, like a lot of many, many hours of work. And I was so excited to not only have something to show for my work, but to have something that was so excited to not only have something to show for my work, but to have something that was so meaningful to me, something that if I think about my family's story and if I think about what I wanted to accomplish with my life, it was so perfectly aligned. And I remember getting the acceptance email from the journal.
这篇论文对我个人意义重大。我非常兴奋能发表它。为了达到这一步，我经历了漫长的艰辛，投入了无数个小时的工作。我不仅为能有成果展示而兴奋，而且因为这对我来说意义非凡，如果考虑到我家庭的故事，考虑到我一生想要实现的目标，它是如此完美地契合。我记得收到了期刊的录用邮件。
You get like a very short email that says, you know, congratulations, like your paper has been accepted for publication. I was in Butler Library and I was crying. I was just so overwhelmed with emotion. And then the immediate thought I had afterwards was, now the difference making finally begins. I was waiting for the New York Times to call. I was waiting for the White House to call. I was waiting for policymakers around the world
你收到一封非常简短的邮件，上面写着“恭喜，你的论文已被录用”。我当时在巴特勒图书馆，我哭了。我被情绪淹没了。随之而来的第一个念头是：现在，改变终于开始了。我在等《纽约时报》的电话。我在等白宫的电话。我在等世界各地的决策者
to get excited by this work. And I waited a day, I waited a week, I waited a month, and nothing happened. I didn't hear from anybody, not a single interview request or media interview. And I started getting really upset. I was like, I did all of this work. I proved something.
对这项工作感到兴奋。我等了一天，等了一周，等了一个月，什么也没发生。我没有收到任何人的消息，没有一个采访请求或媒体采访。我开始感到非常沮丧。我想，我做了这么多工作。我证明了一些东西。
Like, why isn't anybody listening? And I remembered I went to a senior faculty member in the department, Joel Brockner, and I shared with him how frustrated I was that I published this paper in this prestigious journal and nothing had changed. And he kind of laughed and he said, yeah, that's what happens. this paper in this prestigious journal and nothing had changed. And he kind of laughed and he said,
为什么没人听呢？我记得我去找了系里的一位资深教员乔尔·布洛克纳，我告诉他我有多沮丧，因为我在这个权威期刊上发表了论文，却什么也没改变。他笑了笑说：“是的，这就是现实。”我在这个权威期刊上发表了论文，却什么也没改变。他笑了笑说：
yeah, that's what happens. That's very normal for academic research. Sometimes if you build a body of research and you're lucky somebody might listen, but you can't expect a single paper to change the world. I kind of walked out of there really down. I had a hard time making sense of what that meant for me and a hard time making sense of what to do with that information. I'm wondering what your mental state was at this time, Jan. You had come to New York with these very high expectations. You'd read Paul Farmer. You'd wanted to change the world. And you've been through three years of this process that in some ways had ground you down.
“是的，这就是现实。这在学术研究中很正常。有时如果你积累了一系列研究，运气好的话可能会有人听，但你不能指望一篇论文就能改变世界。”我走出办公室时感到非常失落。我很难理解这对意味着什么，也很难理解该如何处理这些信息。简，我想知道你当时的精神状态。你带着极高的期望来到纽约。你读过保罗·法默的书。你想改变世界。你经历了三年的过程，在某种程度上，这已经磨灭了你的意志。
How were you feeling at this point? I was feeling really low. I had a hard time to motivate myself to do more. Like I would stare at my computer screen in my cubicle and I just would ask myself what the heck I'm doing. I could see the words on the screen and I could like read whatever I was supposed to be reading, but it wasn't registering in my mind. It wasn't lighting me up the way that it used to. Like I remember sitting in that very same spot, looking at the very same monitor, like weeks, months and years earlier,
你当时感觉如何？我感觉非常低落。我很难激励自己去做更多的事。我会盯着隔间里的电脑屏幕，问自己到底在做什么。我能看到屏幕上的文字，也能读懂我应该读的东西，但我的大脑没有反应。它不再像以前那样点燃我的热情。我记得坐在同一个位置，看着同一个显示器，几周、几个月、几年前，
and reading things or working on things, writing things, analyzing data, and feeling so fired up on the inside. And here I was, sitting in the same chair, doing the same things, and that feeling wasn't there anymore. Like, it was really discombobulating. Like, I just, I didn't know what to do with myself. I had sacrificed a lot to be there.
读着东西，做着事情，写着东西，分析数据，内心感到无比火热。而现在，我坐在同一把椅子上，做着同样的事情，那种感觉却消失了。这真的让人感到困惑。我不知道该怎么办。我为了来到这里牺牲了很多。
I'd worked many long hours to do this, but I started questioning what it's all worth and what it's all for. Jan's story didn't fit the soaring language of graduation speeches or the sunny promises of inspirational posters. Visionaries tell us that the important thing is to find our passion. Once we identify what we are meant to do, everything is supposed to get easier. But in Jan's experience, this just wasn't so. When we come back, why pursuing our passions often doesn't work out the way we imagine, and what to do about it.
我投入了无数个小时，但我开始质疑这一切到底值不值得，到底是为了什么。简的故事并不符合毕业演讲中那种高昂的语言，也不符合励志海报中阳光般的承诺。梦想家告诉我们，重要的是找到我们的激情。一旦我们确定了自己注定要做的事，一切都应该变得更容易。但在简的经历中，事实并非如此。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么追求激情往往不会如我们想象的那样发展，以及该如何应对。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Follow your dreams. Do what you're passionate about. March to your own drummer. Many people nowadays say they don't just want to work at a job. They want a passion, a calling. At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist Jan Jahimovic studies what happens in the real world when people pursue their passions. What he has found challenges the conventional narrative we often hear. Jan, having seen how you struggled to maintain enthusiasm for your work, you decided to create a personal passion project. You were living in New York, a place where people come from all over the world to follow
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。追随你的梦想。做你热爱的事。走自己的路。如今，许多人说他们不仅仅想找一份工作。他们想要一种激情，一种使命。在哈佛商学院，行为科学家简·贾希莫维奇研究了当人们在现实世界中追求激情时会发生什么。他的发现挑战了我们经常听到的传统叙事。简，在看到你如何努力维持对工作的热情后，你决定开展一个个人激情项目。你当时住在纽约，一个来自世界各地的人们为了追随
their dreams. And you reached out to lots of people you knew and you asked them a simple question. What was this question? So I asked everybody that I knew, all my friends and acquaintances, and I said, who's the most passionate person that you know? Can you put me in touch with them? I want to talk to them." And over the next two years, I ended up talking to over 200 people from all walks of life. I talked to athletes,
梦想而来的地方。你联系了许多认识的人，问了他们一个简单的问题。这个问题是什么？我问了我认识的所有人，所有的朋友和熟人，我说：“你认识的最有激情的人是谁？能帮我联系一下吗？我想和他们谈谈。”在接下来的两年里，我最终与来自各行各业的200多人进行了交谈。我采访了运动员、
musicians, and artists. I talked to entrepreneurs, people in business from CEOs to entry level. People had all types of backgrounds. And the question that I asked them was, have you ever fallen out of passion? And what's that like? And what did you do since to regain it? Because I wanted advice for me. I was the person that I wanted to treat. I was the patient of my own research. And it was just such a learning experience for me that what I ended up hearing again and again ended up changing the trajectory of my career. One of the people you interviewed was a former Canadian tennis player who hit a wall when she was just 23.
音乐家和艺术家。我采访了企业家，从首席执行官到初级员工的商界人士。人们有着各种各样的背景。我问他们的问题是：“你曾经失去过激情吗？那是什么感觉？之后你做了什么来重拾它？”因为我想为自己寻求建议。我就是我想治疗的那个人。我是自己研究的病人。这对我来说是一次学习经历，我反复听到的内容最终改变了我职业生涯的轨迹。你采访的人中有一位前加拿大网球运动员，她在23岁时遇到了瓶颈。
Tell me her story, Jan. So I read this article in the New York Times about Alexandra Wozniak. She had publicly come out that a few years earlier, as she was hitting a career high, she was ranked number 21 in the world, and she then disappeared from the tennis landscape for a few years. And people didn't really know why at the time, but a couple of years later, she came back and she said, look, I was actually experiencing burnout.
简，讲讲她的故事。我在《纽约时报》上读到一篇关于亚历山德拉·沃兹尼亚克的文章。她公开表示，几年前，当她的职业生涯达到巅峰时，她的世界排名曾达到第21位，随后她从网球界消失了几年。当时人们并不真正知道原因，但几年后她回来时说：“看，我实际上经历了职业倦怠。”
I was actually having a really hard time to keep going. And I ended up talking to her and I had asked her, what did you learn in that time period? Like, how do you explain what happened to you when you were 23, when you were at the top of the world, ranked 21st in the world. She had beat Serena Williams. Like, think about that. Like, that's just such an accomplishment.
我当时真的很难坚持下去。我最终和她谈了谈，问她在那段时间里学到了什么。比如，你怎么解释你23岁时发生的事情，当时你正处于世界顶峰，排名世界第21位。她曾击败过塞雷娜·威廉姆斯。想想看，这真是一项了不起的成就。
And what I heard from her was a couple of things. The first thing that I heard is it was really difficult because tennis no longer brought her joy. Like when she was younger and she first entered tennis, there was a different feeling around tennis. But once she became successful, playing a game was no longer about just being good at tennis. Playing the game was now about success, about winning money, about earnings, about competition. She had a reputation to uphold. In Canada, there were a lot of expectations about all that she would be able to accomplish. There was a lot to bear on her shoulders, and it wasn't what she signed up for, and it wasn't something that
我从她那里听到的是几件事。第一件事是，这真的很困难，因为网球不再给她带来快乐。当她年轻刚进入网球界时，对网球的感觉是不同的。但一旦她成功了，打球就不再仅仅是为了擅长网球。打球现在是为了成功，为了赢钱，为了收入，为了竞争。她有声誉要维护。在加拿大，人们对她能取得的成就寄予厚望。她肩上的担子很重，这不是她当初选择的初衷，也不是她
she was adequately prepared for. The other thing is that it ended up becoming a job. It's fine for us to say you should follow what you're passionate about or you should turn your passions into your career. But when you turn something that you're passionate about into a job, now that's a source of income a job, now that's a source of income for us, now that's a source of status, like now that it becomes what do I do day to day? Like how do I keep this going? So she was not the only one who told you that she entered the world of tennis with passion, with love, and then in some ways had fallen out of love with tennis, just like you had
能够充分准备好的。另一件事是，它最终变成了一份工作。我们说你应该追随你的激情，或者你应该把激情变成职业，这没问题。但当你把你热爱的东西变成工作时，它就成了我们的收入来源，成了地位的象征，成了我每天必须做的事情。我该如何维持下去？所以她并不是唯一一个告诉你她带着激情和爱进入网球世界，然后以某种方式对网球失去爱的人，就像你
fallen in some ways out of love with what you were doing you heard this as a common refrain from many of the people you talked with. Almost every single person when I asked them the question have you ever fallen out of passion and if yes like what happened they had a story locked and loaded like they were ready to tell me about a time when they hit emotional rock bottom when they were close to quitting, where they had many friends who were doing the same things who actually ended up quitting. Every single person that I talked to who had experienced this falling out of passion at
在某种程度上对你所做的事情失去了爱一样。你从许多交谈过的人那里听到了这种共同的呼声。几乎每个人，当我问他们“你是否曾经失去过激情，如果是，发生了什么”时，他们都有一个准备好的故事。他们准备好告诉我他们何时触及了情感的谷底，何时接近放弃，他们有许多做同样事情的朋友最终真的放弃了。我交谈过的每一个经历过这种激情丧失的人，在
the moment it happened was incredibly confused, disheartened and deeply frustrated. Like they didn't know what was going on because from their perspective they'd done all the right things. They had figured out what it is that they were passionate about. They had then found a career where they could pursue it and then like Paula Farmer they went all in. They did it and they did it not just for a day or a month, they did it for years. And that wasn't enough. Like, that wasn't enough to stave off this falling out of passion. And because they invested so much of themselves and because it mattered so much to them, when they fell out of passion, it was deeply painful. So you decided that you would start to study passion itself, how it changes, how it fades,
那一刻都感到无比困惑、沮丧和深深的挫败感。他们不知道发生了什么，因为从他们的角度来看，他们做了所有正确的事。他们找到了自己热爱的东西。他们找到了一个可以追求激情的职业，然后像保罗·法默一样全力以赴。他们做到了，而且不仅仅是一天或一个月，他们坚持了几年。但这还不够。这不足以阻止这种激情的丧失。因为他们投入了太多自我，因为这事对他们太重要，当他们失去激情时，那是极其痛苦的。所以你决定开始研究激情本身，它是如何变化的，如何消退的，
what we can do about it. One thing you observed is that just because you're doing something you love, that doesn't mean that your days are going to be easy or enjoyable. In fact, things might be harder. Why is that, Jan? I think there's a number of different challenges that are going on here. The first is that some of the things that we have to do when we pursue our passion, they're not all that glamorous and they're not all that passion evoking. When you're doing research, 99% of the time you spend by yourself looking at a computer screen.
我们能做些什么。你观察到的一件事是，仅仅因为你在做你热爱的事，并不意味着你的日子会变得轻松或愉快。事实上，事情可能会更艰难。简，为什么会这样？我认为这里有许多不同的挑战。首先，我们在追求激情时必须做的一些事情，并不那么光鲜亮丽，也不那么能激发激情。当你做研究时，99%的时间是你一个人盯着电脑屏幕。
You don't really have breakthroughs every single day that fill your cup. The same is true when you're an athlete. It's great when you're out there on the pitch and you get to win a game or be in an amazing position. But often you're behind the scenes, you're weightlifting, you're stretching, you're honing in on how to make your game better, that can be really difficult to maintain, particularly over longer timeframes. There's also a broader challenge when you haven't had a successful outcome in a while. It's really
你并不是每天都能有填补你心灵的突破。运动员也是如此。当你站在赛场上赢得比赛或处于绝佳位置时，感觉很棒。但通常你是在幕后，你在举重、拉伸、磨练如何让你的比赛更好，这在长期来看真的很难维持。当你有一段时间没有取得成功时，也会面临更广泛的挑战。当你感觉不到自己在取得很大进步时，
difficult to keep going when you don't feel like you're making a lot of progress. Like when you're trying to pursue your passion and the only sign that you see in the world is that you're being unsuccessful in doing that. It's difficult to maintain a belief that you are able to do it, particularly when you care so deeply about it. Jan tells the story of entrepreneur Brooke Boyarsky-Pratt. She left a safe and lucrative job to start her own company. It focused on reducing stigma around weight issues, something that was deeply meaningful to her because she had experienced the stigma herself.
真的很难坚持下去。当你试图追求激情，而世界上唯一的迹象是你在这方面并不成功时。很难保持一种你能做到的信念，尤其是当你如此深切地关心它时。简讲述了企业家布鲁克·博亚斯基-普拉特的故事。她放弃了一份稳定且高薪的工作，创办了自己的公司。公司专注于减少关于体重问题的污名，这对她来说意义重大，因为她自己也经历过这种污名。
She was fired up about running her own shop, but also found herself up at all hours of the night. It was really difficult for her. She went from working 40 to 50 hours a week to working 90, 100 hour weeks. I should say that at the time she had just given birth to her first child. So she was expanding her family and it was very emotionally challenging. Like she was no longer working on a particular narrow set of tasks. She was doing everything in the organization. Every task fell to her because she was the CEO and co-founder. She was building a team. She was raising money.
她对经营自己的公司充满热情，但也发现自己整夜不眠。这真的很难。她从每周工作40到50小时变成了每周工作90到100小时。我应该说，当时她刚生下第一个孩子。所以她正在扩大自己的家庭，这在情感上非常有挑战性。她不再只处理一组狭窄的任务。她在组织里什么都做。因为她是首席执行官和联合创始人，每一项任务都落在她身上。她在组建团队。她在筹集资金。
She had to provide proof of concept that this weight inclusive stuff would work. And it was really weird for her because suddenly she was responsible for everything. Like what she was doing was no longer whether she was good at her job, but it was a ruling on who she is as a person. Like this career that she had chosen was now a reflection of her identity. And add on top of that, like what is progress here? Like what does success look like? She's working on this and you know, the whole time she has to ask herself like, when am I ever going to be happy? Like, when is it really that I feel like I have made a difference? We're really fortunate. We taught this a few months ago in the classroom,
她必须提供概念证明，证明这种包容体重的理念是可行的。这让她感到非常奇怪，因为突然间她要对一切负责。她所做的不再是她是否擅长工作，而是对她作为一个人的评价。她选择的这份职业现在成了她身份的反映。再加上，这里的进步是什么？成功是什么样子的？她一直在努力，你知道，她必须一直问自己：“我什么时候才能快乐？我什么时候才真正觉得我有所作为？”我们真的很幸运，几个月前我们在课堂上讲过这个，
and we invited Brooke to come in and do a Q&A with the students. And one of our students asked her, so now that you've quit your job to pursue your passion, are you happier? And she kind of stood there and she was thinking about this for a while and she said, you know, most days it doesn't feel that way. And then the follow-up question from the same student was, so do you regret doing this? And she said, absolutely not. Like she had a clear answer. She knew that it was important to her that she had done this. It was challenging because many of the things she ended up working on weren't all that glamorous. The emotional roller coaster, the ups and downs of success and failure, progress, lack of progress took a major toll on her.
我们邀请布鲁克来和学生们进行问答。我们的一名学生问她：“既然你辞职去追求激情，你更快乐了吗？”她站在那里思考了一会儿说：“你知道，大多数日子里感觉并不那样。”同一名学生接着问：“那你后悔这样做吗？”她说：“绝对不。”她有明确的答案。她知道这对她很重要，她做到了。这很有挑战性，因为她最终从事的许多工作并不那么光鲜。情感过山车，成功与失败的起伏，进步与缺乏进步，对她造成了重大打击。
And it was just really hard, like the amount of work and effort that it took. So you were born and raised in Germany. Your parents are Polish. I understand there are words and concepts in these cultures that speak to this tension that we're discussing here, Jan? We all know that Germans have the best words for everything. So I think there's this German word that I think needs to be part of the English vocabulary. So here's my pitch. The German word for passion is Leidenschaft. Linguists will disagree with me, and this is a very liberal interpretation of the word,
这真的很难，投入的工作和努力太多了。你是在德国出生长大的。你的父母是波兰人。简，我了解到这些文化中有一些词汇和概念可以说明我们正在讨论的这种张力？我们都知道德国人对一切都有最好的词汇。所以我认为有一个德语词汇需要进入英语词汇表。这是我的提议。德语中“激情”一词是“Leidenschaft”。语言学家会不同意我的观点，这是对该词非常自由的解释，
but the word light from Leidenschaft comes from suffering, and schafft comes from ability. And so a very liberal translation of the word Leidenschaft is the ability to endure hardship. It's a very different way of thinking about passion. It maybe tells you a lot about German culture and why Germany is the way that it is, but it's in stark contrast to the American way of thinking about passion. You know, like if you do what you love,
但“Leidenschaft”中的“Leiden”来自“受苦”，“schaft”来自“能力”。因此，“Leidenschaft”的一个非常自由的翻译是“忍受苦难的能力”。这是一种关于激情的非常不同的思考方式。它也许能告诉你很多关于德国文化以及为什么德国是现在这个样子的原因，但它与美国关于激情的思考方式形成了鲜明的对比。你知道，比如如果你做你热爱的事，
you never have to work another day in your life. This idea that if you pursue your passion, it feels magical, it feels easy. The implication being, if it doesn't feel easy, then it cannot be passion. All the research tells us that that's so misleading. The German way of thinking about it, the ability to endure hardship, I think it's an important counterpoint because I think it captures a large part of the experience that we often miss. When you're passionate about something, the day-to-day can be really challenging. The day-to-day can make you feel upset, can make you feel bored, it can make you feel like you have
你这辈子就不用再工作一天了。这种认为如果你追求激情，它就会感觉神奇、感觉轻松的想法。暗示着如果它感觉不轻松，那就不可能是激情。所有的研究都告诉我们，这太误导人了。德国人的思考方式，即忍受苦难的能力，我认为是一个重要的对立面，因为它捕捉到了我们经常忽略的很大一部分体验。当你对某事充满激情时，日常工作可能真的很有挑战性。日常工作可能会让你感到沮丧，可能会让你感到无聊，可能会让你觉得你
to go through all the pain, but you do it anyway. And you do it because you believe in it, you believe that there is worth in doing it despite the suffering that you have to go through. In Polish, there is one translation for passion that is called cierpienie, which literally means suffering. So in Polish, there isn't even any striving. In Polish, you just suffer. That comes from more Christian traditions of the passion of Christ, of really just suffering. So you're suffering not necessarily just because you believe in suffering. So you're suffering, not necessarily just because you believe in it, but you're suffering as a form of sacrifice.
必须经历所有的痛苦，但你还是做了。你这样做是因为你相信它，你相信尽管必须经历苦难，但这样做是有价值的。在波兰语中，有一个激情的翻译叫“cierpienie”，字面意思是“受苦”。所以在波兰语中，甚至没有任何奋斗的含义。在波兰语中，你只是受苦。这更多来自基督教关于基督受难的传统，即真正地受苦。所以你受苦不一定是因为你相信受苦。所以你受苦，不一定是因为你相信它，而是你受苦作为一种牺牲的形式。
So many of us believe that the more we love what we do, the better we are going to be at doing it. In other words, we believe there's a linear relationship between passion and performance. You've studied this question, Jan's a linear relationship between passion and performance. You've studied this question, Jan. Is the connection between passion and performance as straightforward as many of us imagine? It is and it isn't.
我们许多人认为，我们越热爱所做的事，我们就会做得越好。换句话说，我们认为激情与表现之间存在线性关系。简，你研究过这个问题。激情与表现之间的联系是否像我们许多人想象的那样直接？是，也不是。
So we collected data from over 600 employees, and we asked them what generally their orientation was toward their work, whether work was something that generally they went into because they're passionate about it, or whether work is something that they went into because for them it's a career or it's a job, meaning it's not something that they're passionate about, but it still fulfills an important role in their life. In addition to that, literally speaking, people who view their work as a passion, they perform
我们收集了600多名员工的数据，询问他们对工作的总体导向，即工作是他们因为充满激情而从事的事情，还是他们因为职业或工作而从事的事情，这意味着这不是他们充满激情的事情，但它仍然在他们的生活中发挥着重要作用。此外，从字面上看，那些将工作视为激情的人，他们的表现
better at their job. And the mechanisms are exactly along the lines of what you might expect. They were more invested in their work. They were more willing to work longer hours, and that led them to perform better on average. When you look at what happens day to day, what we found was that when people were much more passionate than usual. So when they were feeling particularly fired up, they actually ended up performing worse. What that means is that when they were really, really passionate on any particular day, they were really excited about something.
在工作中更好。其机制正是你可能预期的那样。他们对工作投入更多。他们更愿意工作更长时间，这使他们平均表现更好。当你观察每天发生的事情时，我们发现当人们比平时更有激情时——也就是说，当他们感到特别火热时——他们的表现实际上更差。这意味着当他们在某一天真的、真的充满激情时，他们对某事感到非常兴奋。
They were also kind of nervous and hesitant. They felt ambivalent. They were worried that they would be unable to live up to the really high expectations that they had. These worries started steering them away from performing well. So what we find in this work is that there is such a thing as too much passion. You can feel too passionate for your work and that can be really challenging and it can make you perform worse. Talk about the idea that passions can sometimes cross the line into unhealthy obsessions.
他们也感到有点紧张和犹豫。他们感到矛盾。他们担心自己无法达到他们所设定的极高期望。这些担忧开始使他们无法表现良好。所以我们在研究中发现，激情过犹不及。你可能对工作感到过于充满激情，这可能真的很有挑战性，并可能导致你的表现变差。谈谈激情有时会跨越界限变成不健康的痴迷这一观点。
You and others have studied this idea, Jan. Yeah, absolutely. So this notion of passion as being harmonious or obsessive was first introduced by Bob Valorant. His idea was that passions can come in one or two different ways, that passion can be something that I have some degree of control over, that I can regulate it to some extent. I can choose whether I engage in something I am passionate about.
简，你和其他人研究过这个想法。是的，绝对。这种将激情视为和谐或强迫性的概念最初是由鲍勃·瓦勒兰提出的。他的观点是，激情可以以两种方式之一出现，激情可以是我在某种程度上可以控制的东西，我可以调节它。我可以选择是否参与我充满激情的事情。
I can choose when to stop, stop engaging in it, stop thinking about it, or that my passion becomes obsessive, meaning that my passion ends up controlling me, such that I can't stop how much I'm engaging in something, that my passion just ends up carrying me places. You know, you're up late at night, obsessing over what it is that you're passionate about. You're not getting enough sleep because of it.
我可以选择何时停止，停止参与，停止思考它，或者我的激情变得强迫性，这意味着我的激情最终控制了我，以至于我无法停止参与某事的程度，我的激情最终带我去了某些地方。你知道，你深夜不睡，沉迷于你充满激情的事情。你因为这个而睡眠不足。
And that can be really difficult. There's a tension here, Jan. You mentioned that beautiful German word Leidenschaft, which is in some ways the ability to tolerate hardship. That's what passion is. It's the ability to tolerate hardship, perhaps over long periods of time. And you can see how easily and seamlessly that
这可能真的很难。简，这里存在一种张力。你提到了那个美丽的德语词“Leidenschaft”，在某种程度上是忍受苦难的能力。这就是激情。它是忍受苦难的能力，也许是长期忍受苦难的能力。你可以看到它是多么容易且无缝地
can slip into someone saying, I can do without sleep. I can do without friends. I can do without taking a break or a vacation, because it's my ability to tolerate hardship. On the one hand, we all know that you can't accomplish anything without being willing to put in a lot of time and effort, but there is a time when that can seamlessly slip over into something that is deeply unhealthy. I agree. I think the challenge here is that the line between persevering and obsessing can be really blurry at times, right?
滑向某人说：“我可以不睡觉。我可以没有朋友。我可以不休息或度假，因为这是我忍受苦难的能力。”一方面，我们都知道如果不愿意投入大量时间和精力，你就无法完成任何事情，但确实存在一个时刻，它会无缝地滑向某种极其不健康的东西。我同意。我认为这里的挑战在于，坚持和痴迷之间的界限有时真的非常模糊，对吧？
Like what some people would describe as an amazing feat of perseverance, other people would call an obsessive person, right? Like if I work on something for a really long time, despite the world's telling me that I shouldn't be doing this and I end up being successful, we celebrate that. Look at the fortitude this person had. And so we always are smarter in hindsight, right? Like, that's, I think, the challenge is that in the moment, we ourselves, you have to learn over time how to calibrate and make these decisions. Pursuing a passion can be more complicated and more difficult than we initially imagine.
比如有些人会描述为惊人的毅力，而另一些人会称之为痴迷的人，对吧？比如如果我长时间做某事，尽管全世界都告诉我我不应该这样做，但我最终成功了，我们就会庆祝这一点。看看这个人的坚韧。所以我们总是事后诸葛亮，对吧？我认为这就是挑战，即在当下，我们自己，你必须随着时间的推移学习如何校准并做出这些决定。追求激情可能比我们最初想象的更复杂、更困难。
Discovering what we love is only the first step. The task of keeping ardor alive and balancing our passions with the rest of our lives is much harder. When we come back, better ways to engage and feed our passions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Most people who have been successfully married for a long time will tell you that their relationships have changed dramatically over time.
发现我们热爱的事物只是第一步。保持热情并平衡激情与我们生活的其余部分的任务要困难得多。稍后回来，我们将探讨投入和滋养激情的更好方法。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。大多数长期婚姻幸福的人会告诉你，他们的关系随着时间的推移发生了巨大的变化。
Just because you're in love with the same person for a long time doesn't mean your reasons to be in love are the same reasons you had at the start of the affair. At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist Jan Jahimovic has found that passion in the workplace works the same way. If you want to remain passionate about what you do, you might need to keep reinventing what you do. Jan, in your survey of passionate people,
仅仅因为你长期爱着同一个人，并不意味着你相爱的理由和你开始这段感情时的理由相同。在哈佛商学院，行为科学家简·贾希莫维奇发现工作场所的激情也是如此。如果你想保持对工作的热情，你可能需要不断重塑你的工作。简，在你对充满激情的人的调查中，
one story stood out to you, the story of a chef who was deeply passionate about food. Tell me that story, Jan. So I met this chef, and I asked him what he's passionate about. And this chef just loved cooking. Like you could feel his passion was palpable when he sat across from me. And he described his phase in his career that happened about two years ago. He had worked at a high-end kitchen in New York.
有一个故事让你印象深刻，那是一位对食物充满热情的厨师的故事。Jan，讲讲那个故事吧。我遇到了这位厨师，我问他，他真正热爱的是什么。这位厨师就是热爱烹饪。当你坐在他对面时，你能感受到他的热情是显而易见的。他描述了他职业生涯中大约两年前发生的一个阶段。他曾在纽约一家高端厨房工作。
And for all external markers had reached all of the success that you can imagine. He was advancing in his career. He was finally in a position where as a chef who was passionate about food, like that's where you want to be. But he wasn't feeling that passion anymore. And he had a really hard time making sense of it. He took a more radical step than some of the other people that I talked to. He decided to quit his job and go away for a while.
从所有外部指标来看，他已经取得了你能想象到的所有成功。他的事业蒸蒸日上。作为一名热爱食物的厨师，他终于达到了那个你梦寐以求的位置。但他不再感受到那种热情了。他很难理解其中的原因。他采取了比我采访过的其他人更激进的步骤。他决定辞职，离开一段时间。
So he left New York. He went traveling through Central and Latin America. And two things happened on the trip. The first thing is that he took his camera with him and he ended up taking a lot of pictures. And he realized that he actually also loves taking pictures. The second thing is when he looked through the pictures that he was taking, what he was taking pictures of was of connection, like of people, of moments of joy when they were connecting with other people.
于是他离开了纽约。他去中南美洲旅行。在旅途中发生了两件事。第一件事是他随身带着相机，拍了很多照片。他意识到自己其实也很喜欢摄影。第二件事是，当他翻看自己拍的照片时，他发现自己拍摄的内容是关于连接的，比如人与人之间，以及人们在与他人建立联系时那些快乐的瞬间。
And so what he started realizing for himself was that maybe why he liked cooking or initially why he got into being a chef was because he was passionate about making food for people, for people to share, for people to connect over, for people to see themselves reflected in the food, or have a moment where they feel like this is food that they used to eat, or that's something that brings memories to mind for them, a smell, a taste. And so he ended up coming back from this trip and realizing this high-end
于是他开始意识到，也许他喜欢烹饪，或者他最初成为厨师的原因，是因为他热衷于为人们制作食物，让人们分享，让人们通过食物建立联系，让人们在食物中看到自己的影子，或者在某个瞬间感到这就是他们过去常吃的食物，又或者那是能勾起他们回忆的东西，一种气味，一种味道。所以他结束旅行回来后意识到，这种高端
restaurant life didn't actually allow him to pursue his passion. That was the common path that people took who were passionate for cooking and passionate about food. But that wasn't the path that would make him happy. And instead, when I ended up talking to him, he was working at still a nice restaurant, but that restaurant wasn't focused with excellence, wasn't focused on design, didn't have the same push to perfection as the high-end restaurants. That wasn't the purpose of that restaurant. That wasn't why people were doing what they were doing. That wasn't what he was pushed to do there. Instead, he worked at a restaurant where people cooked and were working because they wanted to provide people
餐厅生活实际上并没有让他追求自己的热情。那是那些热爱烹饪和食物的人所走的共同道路。但这并不是让他快乐的道路。相反，当我最终和他交谈时，他仍在一家不错的餐厅工作，但那家餐厅并不以卓越为重点，不以设计为重点，没有像高端餐厅那样对完美的追求。那不是那家餐厅的目的。那不是人们做他们所做之事的原因。那也不是他在那里被要求做的事情。相反，他在一家餐厅工作，那里的人们烹饪和工作是因为他们想为人们提供
with an experience where they could connect over food. You know, the food was almost like the side dish and the people were the main dish. Whereas if you go to a high-end restaurant, it's all about the food being the main dish and your experience of that food. Would you say that this is generally true of the pursuit of passion in workplace settings, Jan,
一种可以通过食物建立联系的体验。你知道，食物几乎就像配菜，而人才是主菜。然而，如果你去一家高端餐厅，一切都是关于食物作为主菜，以及你对那种食物的体验。Jan，你会说这在职场中追求热情时通常是正确的吗？
which is that for us to maintain our passion, we might need to be open to reinventing what we're passionate about? I think it's the most normal thing that we need to embrace. We ourselves change. The environment around us changes. And so if the way that we pursue our passion doesn't change, then over time there will be a mismatch, right?
也就是说，为了保持我们的热情，我们可能需要对重塑我们所热衷的事物持开放态度？我认为这是我们需要拥抱的最正常的事情。我们自己会变。我们周围的环境也会变。因此，如果我们追求热情的方式不改变，那么随着时间的推移，就会出现错位，对吧？
Because we are changing and the environment is changing, we too have to be flexible in our approach. We need to be cognizant of the ways in which we are changing. And that includes how we pursue our passion. So we talked earlier about how passion is closely linked in our minds to perseverance, our ability to stick to difficult challenges. This seems to be in tension with the idea that we need to be open to changing what we do in order to remain passionate. You write about a woman named Elizabeth Rowe. Tell me her story and how this illustrates this tension, Yan.
因为我们正在改变，环境也在改变，我们也必须在方法上保持灵活。我们需要意识到我们正在改变的方式。这包括我们如何追求我们的热情。我们之前谈到热情在我们的思想中与毅力密切相关，即我们坚持应对困难挑战的能力。这似乎与我们需要为了保持热情而愿意改变我们所做之事的想法相矛盾。你写了一位名叫伊丽莎白·罗（Elizabeth Rowe）的女性。讲讲她的故事，以及这如何说明了这种矛盾，Jan。
Absolutely. I think this is one of the core tensions of what it means to be passionate for what you do. You have a deep belief in something. At the same time, you have to be flexible in figuring out whether or not that still works for you or whether who you are has changed enough for you to warrant a bigger life decision change. So Elizabeth Rowe was the principal flutist for the Boston Symphony Orchestra. She came into this position in the mid 2000s. And just to highlight, to be a principal flutist at the Boston Symphony Orchestra, that is like being at the top of your game.
当然。我认为这是关于热爱你所做之事意味着什么的根本矛盾之一。你对某件事有坚定的信念。同时，你必须灵活地弄清楚这是否仍然适合你，或者你是否已经发生了足够大的变化，以至于需要做出更重大的生活决定。伊丽莎白·罗是波士顿交响乐团的首席长笛手。她在2000年代中期担任这一职位。需要强调的是，作为波士顿交响乐团的首席长笛手，这就像处于你职业生涯的巅峰。
That's one of the most coveted jobs in the industry. And like she was really at the top, at the tippy top of her career. If you're pursuing your passion, if your passion is being a flutist and you look at Elizabeth Rowe, you look at her and you say, wow, this is a person who's done it. And she's done it for many, many years.
那是业内最令人垂涎的工作之一。她确实处于职业生涯的顶峰，最顶端。如果你在追求你的热情，如果你的热情是成为一名长笛手，你看着伊丽莎白·罗，你会说，哇，这是一个已经做到极致的人。而且她已经做了很多很多年了。
At the time she was about 48 years old. This has been a 40 plus year pursuit of passion in the making, culminating in this incredible leadership position at the Boston Symphony Orchestra. But in the last couple of years, Elizabeth started sensing that maybe being in an orchestra wasn't all that she wanted to do with her life,
当时她大约48岁。这是一场历时40多年的热情追求，最终在波士顿交响乐团担任了这个令人难以置信的领导职位。但在过去几年里，伊丽莎白开始感觉到，也许在交响乐团工作并不是她一生中唯一想做的事情，
that maybe there was another chapter that she wanted to explore. And to even have that thought as a principal flutist at the Boston Symphony Orchestra is unheard of. Like, these are positions that people don't quit. These positions are available maybe once every five, every ten years in the industry. This isn't something that people usually do. But she had that thought in her mind. What if I stopped playing music? What else would I be doing with my life?
也许还有另一个她想探索的篇章。即使作为波士顿交响乐团的首席长笛手有这种想法也是闻所未闻的。这些职位是人们不会辞职的。这些职位在业内可能每五年、每十年才出现一次。这不是人们通常会做的事情。但她脑子里有了这个想法。如果我不演奏音乐了会怎样？我还会用我的生命做什么？
What are parts of me that I think I would like to live out? What are something that I want to be doing if I weren't be doing music? And so, hesitantly at first, she started experimenting on the side with coaching. She'd always enjoyed coaching and she started with teaching people who were early in their career, young musicians, and figuring out their challenges. And she'd done this her whole career, but now she started doing a little bit more of this, the COVID pandemic hit. So Elizabeth started asking herself, what if I became a coach for six months?
有哪些部分是我认为我想活出来的？如果我不做音乐，我想要做什么？于是，起初她有些犹豫，开始在业余时间尝试教练工作。她一直很喜欢教练工作，她开始教那些职业生涯早期的人，年轻的音乐家，并找出他们的挑战。她整个职业生涯都在做这件事，但现在她开始更多地做这件事，新冠疫情爆发了。于是伊丽莎白开始问自己，如果我做六个月的教练会怎样？
Then the Boston Symphony Orchestra came back and she still had this idea in her mind. What if I did this full time? And what if I didn't just do this for young musicians? What if I did this for people all over? Like I have a lot of skills. I've been leading a high-performance, high-stress position for more than 20 years now. I've learned a lot about what it means to perform that I could help people with, that I could teach people what to do. People who are not just musicians, but athletes, and people in leadership positions who are
然后波士顿交响乐团恢复了演出，她脑子里仍然有这个想法。如果我全职做这个会怎样？如果我不只是为年轻音乐家做这个呢？如果我为各地的人们做这个呢？我有很多技能。我已经领导了一个高绩效、高压力的职位20多年了。我学到了很多关于表演意味着什么的知识，我可以帮助人们，我可以教人们怎么做。那些不仅是音乐家，还有运动员，以及处于领导职位的人，他们
similarly in some way on stage and have to deliver and have to perform. And I could help them do this. And maybe that might affirm a different part of me. And so in 2022, she took a sabbatical. She took a year off from the Boston Symphony Orchestra and jumped headfirst into becoming a leadership coach. And what she discovered throughout that year of experimenting is that this is what she wanted to do with the rest of her life. That being a musician was fun, it had fulfilled her, and it had run its course, and that it was time for the next chapter in her career. And in August 2024, while the Boston Symphony Orchestra was at Tanglewood, which is a big outdoor performance, she gave her very last concert. She was on there on the stage playing the flute
在某种程度上也同样在舞台上，必须交付成果，必须进行表演。我可以帮助他们做到这一点。也许这可能会肯定我性格中的另一部分。于是，在2022年，她休了长假。她从波士顿交响乐团请了一年假，一头扎进了成为一名领导力教练的事业中。她在这一年的实验中发现，这就是她余生想做的事情。成为一名音乐家很有趣，它满足了她，但它已经走到了尽头，是时候开启职业生涯的下一个篇章了。2024年8月，当波士顿交响乐团在坦格尔伍德（Tanglewood）进行大型户外演出时，她进行了最后一场音乐会。她站在舞台上吹奏长笛，
as part of the orchestra. She soaked it all in, you know, the 3000 people applauding her. And this was the last time that she would ever stand on a stage like this again. Like, just think about that. This is all that she has known her whole life. This has been her whole identity.
作为乐团的一部分。她沉浸在其中，你知道，3000人为她鼓掌。这是她最后一次再站在这样的舞台上了。想想看。这是她一生中唯一知道的事情。这就是她的全部身份。
And yet she talks about this metaphor that has since been really powerful to me. She talks about the trapeze instrument and gymnastics. You know, when you're like, you're swinging and you're holding on to one bar, that can be fun. But to proceed, there's a moment where you swing and you have to let go in order to hold on to the next one.
然而，她谈到了一个对我来说一直非常有力的隐喻。她谈到了空中飞人和体操。你知道，当你摆动并抓住一根横杆时，那可能很有趣。但要继续前进，有一个时刻你需要摆动，并且必须放手才能抓住下一根。
But there's this moment between letting go of one thing and holding on to the other thing when you're in the air, and you kind of don't really have a lot of control anymore because you're in motion, and you hope that you're going to catch it. But that's the only way to get there, is to let go and to let that in. It takes a huge amount of courage to do that,
但在放手一件事和抓住另一件事之间，当你身处空中时，有一个时刻，你因为处于运动中而不再有太多的控制权，你希望你能抓住它。但这是到达那里的唯一方法，就是放手并让它发生。这样做需要巨大的勇气，
to let go of something that you are so good at, to be at the top of it. But for her, it's what was required in order to feel fulfilled. You mentioned the word courage, and I want to add the idea of sunk costs. She had spent at this point 40 years preparing and perfecting a career and perfecting her ability to play the flute.
放弃你如此擅长的事情，放弃处于顶峰的状态。但对她来说，这是感到满足所必需的。你提到了“勇气”这个词，我想加上“沉没成本”的概念。此时她已经花了40年时间准备和完善职业生涯，完善她吹奏长笛的能力。
To walk away from that feels like, almost like betrayal, like you're giving up a part of yourself. And she must have had doubts asking, you know, am I being true to the person I was for half my life? You know, to get up and do this other thing. What if I don't like it the other tomorrow? She had a lot of doubts. And to say that she did this without any doubt would be a misrepresentation. I think that what it means to me to have courage is to say, I think I've made the right decision, even though I'm not fully sure whether it's going to work out
放弃这一切感觉就像背叛，就像你放弃了自己的一部分。她一定有过怀疑，问自己：“我是否忠于我半生以来所成为的那个人？”你知道，站起来去做另一件事。如果明天我不喜欢它怎么办？她有很多怀疑。说她毫无怀疑地做到了这一点是不准确的。我认为对我来说，拥有勇气意味着说：“我认为我做出了正确的决定，尽管我不完全确定它是否会成功。”
the way that it did. She can't go back to the Boston Symphony Orchestra. That door is closed, right? Like, that's just not how this industry works. But that's why this time period of experimentation was so helpful for her. When she was on sabbatical for a year, she didn't play the flute at all. She locked it up, put it in a box, stowed it away in a cupboard, and she wanted to realize, like, would this be something that I miss? And she realized, I'm a perfectly capable human being, and I am someone even when I am not a flute player. I have value.
就像它发生的那样。她无法回到波士顿交响乐团。那扇门已经关上了，对吧？这就是这个行业的运作方式。但这就是为什么这段实验期对她如此有帮助的原因。当她休长假一年时，她根本没有吹长笛。她把它锁起来，放进盒子里，收进柜子里，她想弄清楚，这会是我怀念的事情吗？她意识到，我是一个完全有能力的人，即使我不是长笛演奏者，我依然是我。我有价值。
The other way that she was able to make this transition is to realize, yes, there's 40 years of sunk cost of me having learned this instrument, but I've also invested for 40 years on a particular set of skills that can be really helpful to do something else. One of the things you've observed, Jan, is that sometimes in order to keep passion alive, we need to look for aspects of jobs that we care about. Sometimes the things that really lift us up are not in our literal job descriptions.
她能够完成这种转变的另一种方式是意识到，是的，我学习这种乐器有40年的沉没成本，但我也投入了40年时间掌握了一套特定的技能，这些技能对于做其他事情也非常有用。Jan，你观察到的事情之一是，有时为了保持热情，我们需要寻找我们关心的工作方面。有时真正提升我们的东西并不在我们的字面工作描述中。
This was the case for your own mother. Her life took a new direction when she found herself laid off. What happened? My mother worked as a secretary and during the financial crisis lost her job in 2008-2009. She was offered retraining and so took retraining for another profession, trying to find another office job that required new software skills that would hopefully make her more appealing to a broader audience of different organizations. But she was unable to find a job everywhere where she applied. She wasn't taken. At that time, she was in her 50s. She really wanted to work and she
你母亲的情况就是这样。当她发现自己被解雇时，她的生活有了新的方向。发生了什么？我母亲曾是一名秘书，在2008-2009年的金融危机期间失业了。她获得了再培训的机会，于是参加了另一个专业的再培训，试图找到另一份需要新软件技能的办公室工作，希望这能使她在更广泛的组织中更具吸引力。但她到处申请都找不到工作。她没有被录用。那时，她已经50多岁了。她真的很想工作，而且
was getting really frustrated not having a job. And so after more than a year of trying to get another job, retraining, not getting another job, she recalls this moment when she was walking on the way to the retraining school where she was going and she was walking past this retirement home and she heard the women inside that were working in the kitchen singing. And to her mind, it was weird because she thought, wait, they're working in the kitchen. That's not a particularly glamorous and fun job. They seem really happy over there. I wonder what's going on." And so the next day she took her CV and she went into the retirement home and she said, you know, do you have a job available? I would love to work. I'd love to see
因为没有工作而感到非常沮丧。所以，在尝试找另一份工作、再培训、却没能找到工作一年多之后，她回忆起那天她走在去再培训学校的路上，经过一家养老院，听到里面在厨房工作的女性在唱歌。在她看来，这很奇怪，因为她想：“等等，她们在厨房工作。那不是一份特别光鲜有趣的工作。她们在那里看起来真的很开心。我想知道发生了什么。”第二天，她带着简历走进养老院说：“你知道吗，你们有空缺职位吗？我很想工作。我很想看看
what this is like. And so she ended up taking a job as a member of the cleaning staff in this retirement home. You know, and you would think on its surface, it's not necessarily a job that is very fulfilling, like what you do day to day, that doesn't bring you a lot of passion. This actually ended up being the job what my mom would describe as like the most passionate job that she ever had. And she held onto it until she ended up retiring a few years ago. At the time when my mother took this job, she had been in the country, she'd been in Germany for almost 30 years. She had a lot of experience and expertise of what it's like to be an immigrant in Germany,
这是什么样的。”于是她最终在养老院找到了一份清洁工的工作。你知道，从表面上看，你可能会认为这不是一份非常有成就感的工作，比如你每天所做的事情，并不能给你带来很多热情。这实际上最终成了我妈妈所描述的她做过的最充满热情的工作。直到几年前她退休，她一直坚持做这份工作。我母亲做这份工作时，她已经在德国待了近30年。她有很多作为移民在德国生活的经验和专业知识，
how to deal with the authorities, how to figure out how to integrate into this society that at the same time was so foreign, but it also become a home for her. And a lot of the people that worked there were immigrants who were younger than her and who had come to the country a lot more recently than she had. And so she was able to take on a role of advising them about how to navigate this place, how to figure out which authorities to go to, how to make sense of cultural mismatches and clashes that were difficult to explain. She ended up driving one of her colleagues to work because this person was worried about driving in Germany because the drivers in Germany were so intense.
如何与当局打交道，如何弄清楚如何融入这个既陌生又成为她家园的社会。在那里工作的许多人都是比她年轻的移民，他们来到这个国家的时间比她晚得多。因此，她能够承担起建议他们的角色，告诉他们如何在这个地方导航，如何弄清楚该去哪些当局，如何理解难以解释的文化错位和冲突。她最终开车送她的一位同事去上班，因为这个人担心在德国开车，因为德国的司机太猛了。
She had a hard time figuring out how to drive on these streets. And it was such a fulfilling place for my mother. And it really taught me. There's jobs where the tasks that you get to do on its surface feel like they're very fulfilling and very meaningful and that what you do is very passion-evoking. And then there's jobs like this one where my mother was a member of the cleaning staff and ostensibly we would look at it from a societal perspective and say, surely people aren't passionate in this job, but this was the job that my mom was the most passionate about in her whole career.
她很难弄清楚如何在这些街道上开车。这对我的母亲来说是一个非常有成就感的地方。它真的教会了我。有些工作，你所做的任务从表面上看感觉非常有成就感和意义，你所做的事情非常能激发热情。然后还有像我母亲这样的工作，她是清洁工，从社会角度来看，我们表面上会说，人们肯定不会对这份工作充满热情，但这却是我妈妈整个职业生涯中最充满热情的工作。
I understand that you had a startling moment of reevaluation when you went back and reread that book that had so inspired you as a young man. This is a mountains beyond mountains about Paul Farmer. When you went back and read the book, what did you notice about Paul Farmer's life this time around, Jan? When I was younger and I read it for the first time, I was so focused on what he was doing, the difference that he was making, all the amazing things that he was
我了解到，当你回去重读那本曾深深激励你年轻时的书时，你经历了一个令人震惊的重新评估时刻。这就是关于保罗·法默（Paul Farmer）的《超越群山》（Mountains Beyond Mountains）。当你回去读这本书时，这一次你注意到了保罗·法默生活的什么，Jan？当我年轻时第一次读它时，我太专注于他在做什么，他正在产生的差异，以及他正在完成的所有惊人的事情。
accomplishing. I wasn't paying attention to all the things that he wasn't describing or all the things that he wasn't doing. Like, Paul Farmer, for all the amazing accomplishments that he has had, he wasn't happy. You know, it wasn't like he would ever sit back and say, look at all the amazing things I have accomplished. I have changed the way that we think about public health, particularly in low-income countries, changed the way that we think about tuberculosis care. Like, so many things where you see the impact that his organization and his work have had. Instead, what you see in this book that Tracy Kitter wrote is that no matter what Farmer ended up doing, there was always this belief that he had,
我没有注意到他没有描述的所有事情，或者他没有做的所有事情。比如，保罗·法默，尽管他取得了所有惊人的成就，但他并不快乐。你知道，他从来不会坐下来对自己说：“看看我取得的所有惊人成就。我改变了我们对公共卫生的看法，特别是在低收入国家，改变了我们对结核病护理的看法。”比如，你看到他的组织和工作所产生影响的许多事情。相反，你在特雷西·基德（Tracy Kidder）写的这本书中看到的是，无论法默最终做了什么，他总是有一种信念，
there's always more than I can do. I'm always and perpetually dissatisfied because I'm always falling short of the aspiration that I have. And it's something that I think I've internalized now that I've been doing this for a little bit. And I've seen this in a lot of people that I've spoken with. When you pursue what you're passionate about, I think that's just part of what it means. And I don't think this is something that I personally will ever be able to resolve. And more and more, I've come to understand that perhaps not resolving it is what keeps
总有比我能做的更多的事情。我总是处于永久的不满中，因为我总是达不到我的抱负。这是我现在做了一段时间后内化了的东西。我在我交谈过的许多人身上也看到了这一点。当你追求你所热衷的事情时，我认为这只是它意味着什么的一部分。我不认为这是我个人永远能够解决的事情。而且我越来越理解，也许不解决它正是保持
the passion alive. Because by not resolving it, you have to continue finding new solutions, new ways of tackling it, new ways that you're trying to figure it out. But ultimately, you have to find comfort in the fact that maybe you will never be able to resolve it and part of you is always going to be unhappy and dissatisfied. Yann Yahimovitch is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. Yann, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me, Shankar. If you're feeling burned out or lackluster at work, Jan has a set of questions he suggests you should ask yourself.
热情活力的原因。因为通过不解决它，你必须继续寻找新的解决方案，新的应对方式，新的你试图弄清楚的方法。但最终，你必须在这样一个事实中找到安慰：也许你永远无法解决它，你的一部分永远会感到不快乐和不满。Yann Yahimovitch是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。Yann，非常感谢你今天参加Hidden Brain节目。谢谢你邀请我，Shankar。如果你在工作中感到精疲力竭或缺乏动力，Jan有一套他建议你应该问自己的问题。
In our companion story exclusively on Hidden Brain Plus, Jan shares those questions with you and also explains the subtle but crucial distinction between asking what we care about and asking what we care about and asking what we love. Turns out one of them is a much better predictor of long term passion. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled, How to Stop Feeling Burned Out. If you're not yet subscribed, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
在我们Hidden Brain Plus独家播出的配套故事中，Jan与你分享了这些问题，并解释了询问“我们关心什么”与询问“我们热爱什么”之间微妙但至关重要的区别。事实证明，其中一个对长期热情的预测要准确得多。如果你是订阅者，该剧集现在即可收听。标题是《如何停止感到精疲力竭》。如果你还没有订阅，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。
If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. What is Hidden Brain? Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell,
如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以访问apple.co.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。什么是Hidden Brain？Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quirell、
Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Do you have follow-up questions for Jan Jahimovic about identifying and following your passions? If you'd be comfortable sharing your question with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject
Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick和Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。你对Jan Jahimovic关于识别和追随你的热情有什么后续问题吗？如果你愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享你的问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题
line passion. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Finally, Hidden Brain is turning 10 this year and to celebrate, I'm criss-crossing the country for a series of live shows. I'll share 7 key insights from the first decade of the show. To see if I'm coming to a city near you, please visit hiddenbrain.org slash tour. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
行“passion”。那个电子邮件地址再次是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。最后，Hidden Brain今年成立10周年，为了庆祝，我正在全国各地进行一系列现场演出。我将分享该节目第一个十年的7个关键见解。要查看我是否会去你所在的城市，请访问hiddenbrain.org/tour。我是Shankar Vedantam，很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。